yeah there's some libertarian
um candidates for president
and just libertarian thinkers that had
a nice thought experiment of
possibly legalizing i've spoken about
possibly legalizing
basically all drugs in your intuition
do you think a world where all drugs are
legal
is a safer world or a less safe world
for the users of those drugs it really
depends on what we mean by legalization
so this is one of my beefs with
this you know how these things are
talked about i mean we have very few
completely laissez-faire you know
legal drug so even caffeine is one of
the few examples so for example caffeine
and tea and coffee
is in that realm like there's no limits
no one's testing there's no laws
regulation at any level of how much
caffeine you're allowed to buy or how
much energy but even like with this um
starbucks like nitro there are rules
with soda
and with canned products you can only
put so much in there yeah yeah so
there's
this is fda regulated and it's kind of
weird because there's a limit to sodas
that's not there for energy drinks and
other things so
but you know so even caffeine it depends
on what product we're talking about you
like
if you're like nodos and other caffeine
products over the counter like you can't
just put 800 milligrams in there the
pills are like one or two hundred
milligrams
and so it's fda regulated as an
overcounter drug some of the most
dangerous drugs in
society i would say arguably one of the
most dangerous classes of drugs with the
volatile anesthetics huffing
people huffing gasoline and you know
airplane glue toluene
what not um severely damaging to the
nervous system
pretty much legal but there's some
regulation in the sense that there's a
warning label like it's illegal to do it
for
not that it neces people they're busting
people for this
but you know it's against federal law to
use this in a way other than
intended type basically saying yeah
don't huff this you know
um your paint thinner whatnot at least
keeps people from selling it for that
like no because they're gonna they're
gonna go after that person they're not
gonna be able to find the 12 year old
who's huffing
so anyway just as some extreme examples
at
the end and then you know even the
so-called illegal
like schedule one drug psilocybin we do
plenty and um
in terms of schedule two which is
ironically less restrictive than
psilocybin but methamphetamine and
cocaine i've done human research with
my research has been legal so they're
scheduled compounds but they're not
completely illegal like you can
do research with them with the
appropriate licensees and
um uh approval so there really is no
such thing and like alcohol
well it's illegal if you're 12 years old
or 18 years old or 20 years old
and for anyone it's illegal to to be
drinking it while you're driving so
there's always a nuance there's rules
not dichotomy
and i actually should admit it's been on
my to-do list for a while to buy in
massachusetts
some like edible or just buy weed
legally
i um yeah haven't done that
massachusetts let's put it this way
and i i wonder what that experience is
like because i get i think it's fully
legal
in massachusetts and so i wonder what
legal drugs look like
to me you know i grew up with even weed
being like
you know not it's like this forbidden
thing you know not not forbidden but
it's illegal you know most people of
course i never partook but
most people i knew would attain it
illegally
and so that big swish that's been
happening across the country
there's like federal stuff going on to
make uh marijuana
legal federally i'm half paying
attention there's some movement there i
mean the house passed a bill that's not
going to be passed by the
by the senate but yeah it's it's
impressive there's
clearly a change in right it's moving in
a trend so that's the example of a drug
that
used to be illegal it's not becoming
more and more and more legal
um so like i wonder what like uh
cocaine being legal looks like right
what a society with cocaine being legal
looks like the rules around it the
you know the processes in which you can
consume it in a safer way
and be more educated about its
consequences be able to control
dose and like purity much better
be able to get help for overdose i don't
know all those kinds of things
i it does in a utopian sense
feel like legalizing drugs
at least should be talked about and
considered versus uh
keeping them in the dark i agree but
yeah so that in your sense
it's possible that in 50 years uh we
legalize all drugs
and uh it makes for a better world the
way i like to talk about it is that
i would say that we it's possible and it
would probably be a good thing if we
regulate
all drugs how would you regulate uh like
cocaine for example is there
is there ideas there so yeah and you
were already you know going
you know where i was going with that
kind of first i described how there's
always a nuance and even like
the cannabis in massachusetts federally
illegal so for example if i was like
and i you know colleagues that do
cannabis research where they get people
high in the lab like you're a federal
funded researcher with nih funds you
can't get that that stuff from the
dispensary because
you're breaking a federal law even
though the feds don't have the resources
to go after they don't want the
controversy at this point to go after
the individual users or even the
the sellers in those legal states so
there's always this nuance but it's
it's about right the right regulation so
i think we already know enough that
for example like i think safe injection
sites for hard drugs
um makes a lot of sense like i wouldn't
want um
heroin and cocaine at the convenience
stores and i don't think maybe there's
some extreme libertarians that want that
i think even the folks that
identify as libertarians probably most
of them don't well i don't know like not
all of them want that
you know um i think you know that as a
form of regulation like look if you're
using these hard drugs on a
on a regular basis you're putting
yourself at risk for lethal overdose
you're putting yourself at risk for
catching um hiv
and and hepatitis um
if you're gonna do it if you're doing it
anyway come to this place where at least
you're not like
you know like pulling the the water out
of like
you know the puddle on the side of the
street yeah so it's done by
professionals and those professionals
are able to educate you also
so like a 7-eleven clerk may not be both
capable
of of helping you to uh
to inject the drug properly but also
won't be equipped to educate you at but
the negative consequences all those
kinds of things that's a huge part of it
the education but then i
i think with the opioids like the the
big part of it is just like
with naloxone which is an antagonist it
goes into the
um the receptor it's called narcan
that's the trade name but
it's what they revive people on an
opioid overdose that's almost completely
effective
like if there's a medical professional
there and someone's odd on an opioid
they're virtually guaranteed to live
like that's remarkable
that if 100 at the opioid crisis
you know if all of those people right
now that are dying we're doing that in
the presence of a medical professional
like even
like a nurse with narcan there'd be
basic almost no deaths there's always
some exceptions but
you know almost no deaths like that's
staggering to me so the idea that people
are doing this
you know that we could have that level
of positive effect
without encouraging the drug and this is
where like you get into this like
terrain of like sending the wrong
message and it's like
no you can do that you can say like
we're not
encouraging this in fact probably one of
the greatest advertisements
for not getting hooked on heroin is like
visiting a methadone clinic visiting a
safe injection site like
like this is not like an advertisement
for getting hooked on this
drug but knowing that we can save people
now you have a landscape here because
a lot of times it's just like supervised
injection but you bring your own stuff
you know you bring your own heroin which
could still be you know dirty
and and filled with fentanyl and
fentanyl derivatives
which because of the incredible potency
and the more difficulty
measuring it and some differences at the
receptor like you may be more likely
you are more likely on average to
lethally overdose on it
you know so you you could the the level
that's been more explored in switzerland
is uh
in some places is is you actually
provide the drug itself
and you supervise the injection so i
don't like that idea
yeah i the public health data are
completely on the side of there there's
really no credible evidence to this
if we allow that we're sending the wrong
message and everyone's gonna i mean
i'm not showing up like you know and
it's different by drug like yeah you you
legalize you set up cannabis shops and
some people are going to say
i'm going to go there i don't think a
whole lot of people are going to go to
one of these places
and say i'm going to shoot up heroin for
the first time because and even if like
you know
it's a country of 300 million people
like even if someone does that
you have to compare this to the every
day people are dying from
opioid overdoses like people's kids
people's uncles people's like these are
real lives that are being shattered so
you just look at that and then the other
thing and i know this from having done
residential even like non-treatment
research where we just have a cocaine
user or something
stay on our inpatient word for a month
and you really get to know them and
sometimes you see
like oftentimes that's the first time
this person has had a discussion
with a medical professional any type of
professional in their entire life around
their drug use
yeah even if they're not looking to quit
and it's like i i you know you could
imagine that in in these safe injection
settings where
it's like it might be a year into
treatment and they're like you know
doc i know you're not the cops like you
really care for me like
i think i'm ready to try that methadone
thing i think i'm really
i think i want to be a conversation
about it yeah yeah they get to trust the
people
and and realize that they're they're
there because they truly like they have
a compassion a love
for for this community like as human
beings and they don't want people to die
and you get real human connections and
that and again like
those are the conditions where people
are going to ultimately seek treatment
and not everyone always will
but you're go you're gonna get that and
then you're you know you're gonna get
people like looking into treatment
options sometimes
you know maybe years into to the
treatment so it's like there's just all
of these indirect benefits that i think
at that level
i don't know if you'd call that
legalizing you know i think again ra
at least well regulated right whatever
that word is
yeah well regulated but uh out in the
open
right minimizing as many harms as we can
um while not encouraging
i mean we don't encourage people to
drink all the i mean people die every
year from
caffeine overdose like you know there's
different ways to like you know just by
allowing something doesn't mean we're
sending the message that
you know by saying we're not going to
give you a felony which is actually
often the
the the the penalty for for psychedelics
i just actually testified for the
judiciary
committee the the senate the assembly in
in new jersey
and um just to move psilocybin from a
felony to misdemeanor
they use different language in new
jersey it's weird but like the
equivalent of felony missed me and that
was like
two people didn't vote for that on the
on this committee
because it was might one of them said it
might be sending the wrong
message and it's like a felony
i mean there's real harms like that's
the scarlet letter the rest of your life
you're stuck at the lower ends of the
employment ladder you're not going to
get you know loans for education
all of this maybe because of a stupid
mistake he made once as a 19 year old
yeah doing something that like you know
a presidential candidate could have done
and admitted to and
had no problem you know yeah
you